all right uh let's get started so today
we're finishing our first kind of piece
of the tour of the very basics of
supervised uh learning we're going to
talk about these family of models that's
called the exponential family of models
and why we care about these models as we
talked about is they're going to allow
us to generalize basically the kinds of
models that we were using before to a
wider range of error modes okay of
different kinds of errors and they'll
also come back and play a starring role
when we start to tackle unsupervised
learning where we don't have access to a
Target variable and the underlying
mechanics that we'll use here will set
us up quite nicely for that just in
terms of pacing in terms of the course
what happens is I go away for a little
while telling you is going to come in
and talk to you about a bunch of
different things kernels svms and deep
learning and then I'll come back to
teach you a little bit about the
unsupervised learning piece which is
again like a you know two-week block
where we kind of see you know kind of
from first principles how those things
work and that area I have to say just as
a plug for what's coming
um that that area is something that's
been really exciting kind of thrilling
over the last couple of years how much
we can learn without label data or with
really weak sources of data that's been
like a revolution in machine learning so
hopefully I can share some of that
excitement with you okay uh the threat
is up the lecture threat is up on Ed if
you want to ask questions as usual and
everything's online
um before the lecture I didn't put out a
template today because I'm going to
handwrite almost everything so
all right so what are we doing today
we're going to learn about these
exponential family models and they're
basically going to be what you already
know with slightly fancier notation
basically we've been ramping up the
fancier notation each time and
generalizing as appropriate how we want
to go through them
we'll go do the definition and the
motivation and the definition at first
will look like at simultaneously like a
little bit weird and like kind of like
oh that doesn't really mean anything it
doesn't have any content and then it
will also look to you like it's
impossible to satisfy and that's kind of
true right so these are fairly
interesting objects we're going to be
looking at but they have a very nice
kind of canonical form
we'll then do a bunch of examples a
couple of different examples and the
notes Here the master notes here are
really good I would definitely recommend
going through them the type notes just
so you work through a couple of details
this is something that like you're going
to get like a high level piece of how we
go through it just do the calculations
once and you will be convinced of like
all the different claims that are in the
lecture if you try to reason about them
without doing the calculations it just
makes your life more difficult than it
needs to be so just just go through it
once it shouldn't take uh take too long
but I'll give you kind of a high level
tour today so we'll do that definition
of motivation we'll do a couple of
examples and then last time we were
talking about uh this question of how do
we deal with multiple classes right last
time we were talking about binary
classes yes or no now if we want to have
multiple classes out there you want to
know if there's a dog or a pig or a
horse or whatever in there this is
called multi-class classification and
we'll talk a little bit about our
friends softmax what you'll really get
out of this is that it will look kind of
to you in the end like oh okay that
seems pretty reasonable but you'll learn
about some encoding that is fairly
widespread called the one hot encoding
which you would need practically if you
were going to actually use any of these
kind of things I believe also your
homework is out but I don't don't quote
me on that I think it's out now and I
saw there were some questions I had a
class about that any other questions
before we get started
oh please
oh yeah I'm the wrong person but you're
free to ask like just tell you like I
don't know
oh yeah yeah so we are blessed at
Stanford with many great things we have
wonderful weather we have like
incredible faculty we have the best
students on the planet
um and we're also going to create course
support until I have no idea
all right so let's see what's next
Okay so
the exponential family now I want to be
clear like I have mixed feelings about
how I present this because on one hand I
want to convey to you like The
Unbelievable historical significance of
this and why you should know this uh
kind of by rights of machine learning on
the other side like there's an argument
to be made that a lot of modern machine
learning is not going to use this this
formulation in this framework but if you
start to read papers it's canonical
enough that it will come up in various
different places okay so I don't want
you thinking like oh this is all you can
do when you model machine learning this
is like where the field is stopped it's
important historically it is very nice
to understand it has a bunch of
properties we care about but it's it's
not the state of the art right it's not
what we it's not what I go home and you
know use exponential family models it's
weird that I go home and use any of
these things but but and I do um but
it's not this one okay
all right so what we want to do
uh is we want to have the following idea
here is that and this is why it was it's
so beautiful and and will come back as a
form that we want to think about
if P has a special form which I'll show
below
special form
then
some questions come for free some
uh you know inference
learning
come for free now what do I mean by for
free I mean what you already know
automatically applies to them okay and
when we start to worry about more
complicated models this will form like a
subroutine that we'll use again and
again like oh if we can reduce it to
that form then we're in we're in good
shape that'll be the way we get to
things like unsupervised learning
all right now
the form looks like this
okay now one thing I should I should
highlight as I go through this
so this is the data which you know you
already know this character so data
labels
this thing is called the natural
parameters okay and I'll Define the form
in a second the reason I want to
highlight that is one place where you're
likely to get kind of tripped up when we
go through this is that there are kind
of three sets of parameters and I'll
come back to that later so if you're
confused there'll be natural parameters
canonical parameters whatever doesn't
matter you'll see them all written down
at one point and that will kind of
explain the mappings between them but
there are many different names for
parameters in this lecture and and
that's like the essence to understand it
and the reason that's important is the
natural parameters if you like are so we
can write this form this functional form
P of Y
exponential
this is where it gets the exponential
name
T of Y
minus a of okay
so I'm going to unpack this for a second
okay now
this form says basically my probability
distribution factors if you like or can
be written in this form not every
probability distribution can okay the
way you show that a probability
distribution can be written in this form
is you write it in this form okay
there's no secret shortcut here right
you have to be able to express it as
some linear thing in the parameter so
this is the parameters here these
natural parameters times some T of Y
I'll unpack that in one second what T of
Y is minus this thing which is the
partition function okay so that's what
it says it says that your your function
right there are many functions that are
in the world that could be probability
densities this one has this technical
form okay we'll unpack this this
shouldn't be like obvious that these
things are important or exist so T of Y
is called the sufficient statistics
efficient statistics
now in this course primarily we'll use
T of y equal to y
we won't kind of massage the data but
you can kind of think about t of Y as
capturing everything that's relevant to
your data right these are the things
that you're modeling that are in your
data and so in this example like we're
keeping everything T of Y being equal to
y means just it's y itself okay now
another thing people get confused about
this is necessarily the same dimension
foreign
right why is that well we take their dot
product okay this is a DOT product here
you can think about this I'll write it
above just so you clear also you could
write it like this if that's more clear
to you it's an inner product between the
two okay so to take the inner product
and for it to be meaningful those have
to be vectors of exactly the same
Dimension okay so you have if you want
to have so many parameters you have to
have so many sufficient statistics right
okay so far so good
B of Y
is called the base measure
it's not the most critical element here
but you need it okay the ex the
intellectual content of that is that b
depends on y but it does not depend on
not depend on
beta okay so it says basically if you
like what's going on here is this term
has all the interactions with Y this
term has some interactions with ETA and
the only way that ETA and and t y
interact is through this term
okay it's really a statement about how
they interact these functions are pretty
powerful right those are just arbitrary
functions but when they interact they
interact in a linear way sometimes these
are generalized linear models okay all
right keep staring at it
this character A is often called The Log
partition function
now
this is a weird comment that I'm going
to make
okay and it does not depend on well it's
friend it doesn't depend on y just as I
just said does not depend on why
okay now this thing is picked
effectively
as a way of normalizing the distribution
so it's a probability so it sums to one
when I integrate it or I sum up over the
discrete values
all the Y's
it's going to sum to one so that may
make you think that a in some way is
like not the star of the show you know
it's just this thing that kind of like
adds up everything but actually this log
partition function contains almost all
the information it turns out of the
function and that's a weird thing but
it's true okay so talk about that so
this contains a and then you have this
linear interaction term where the
statistics interact with the data
okay now
just to make sure it's clear
Y A and B are scalars
scalar functions so
a of ETA B of Y are scalars
okay just to make sure the types are
clear
and these two characters have the same
dimension
okay
so far so good all right so let's
highlight where everyone where all these
characters are so you just see them
visually same
and wise okay
so far so good all right now here's the
crazy thing
many of the distributions that you've
encountered in your life I don't know
how often you encounter distributions
but if you encounter them at a relative
frequency a lot of them are of this form
and that was a huge win for statistics
because they said all the stuff we're
doing on distributions a lot of it can
be mapped into this what looks like as I
said a trivial statement and the same
time seems also impossible that it would
be there so let's look at some examples
and see how we map into this form
probably you're thinking about you are
going through some distributions in your
head if you look at them and you're like
I'm not sure that it is of that form so
let's look at the simplest version of
that and see that actually yep these
things are of the form so let's look at
some examples
okay
before doing that example I just want to
are there any questions about about the
content of this and I'm happy to defer
so please feel free to ask a question
and I can tell you to defer if there's
something else
clear enough please
don't worry about X they'll come back in
a minute yeah yeah wonderful wonderful
Point yeah there's no X here there's
just a y which is your data there's no
x's and features and they're going to
make it they're going to make a an
appearance uh later they will be one of
these parameters
it's not given it's remember it's our
semicolon
those are the parameters remember
there's a bar which says given which is
condition and there's a semicolon which
says these are parameters
yeah see there's these Ada are the
parameters of the model right and and
they're going to sweep up all that nasty
notation that I talked about last time
wonderful questions
please
why does that mean Q5 is also a Spirit
uh and some of the examples that we'll
see you later yes yeah
it doesn't need to be yeah just for just
to make my life a little bit simpler in
this in this class it's not a
requirement of the model yeah
awesome
wonderful questions
okay this is a requirement just so we're
clear
these have to have the same dimensions
otherwise it doesn't make sense I'm not
saying something deep I'm just saying
like otherwise it will your brain should
segful like what am I taking a thing and
multiplying it by
okay
right because this has this entire
expression has to be a scalar for it to
make sense
okay great
so let's take a look at an example so
probably the first example that you
should think about I would guess are
bernoullis right Bernoulli random
variables
so what are these so we're going to have
some Phi probability of an event right I
guess the most common thing people use
is like flipping a biased coin right for
some probability that it's had some
probability that's tail something like
this
so here
when we've seen this before
Phi
it had this form remember this form that
we used maybe this looks a little bit
familiar
one minus y okay
so the probability of Y uh you know for
one is Phi and when Y is one
um this term when Y is zero it's this
term
okay just a compact way to write it P
and 1 minus p is all I'm writing here if
you think about kind of a heads Tails
distribution
all right so this is not obviously of
the form let's go get the form let's go
get our friend
from up above
how are we going to put it in this form
okay
and I'll draw a box around it
all right
now
when we do this we are like well we got
to get an X somewhere right I mean that
seems pretty natural so we're gonna
we're gonna put an X in there and we're
gonna X above y log
Phi plus 1 minus y
log
1 minus 5. okay
so far so good we're making a little bit
of progress
well the problem we have right now is
the Y's are interacting in two places
right
so what do we have to do well we have to
bring all the Y's together because the
Y's and the fives the parameters like
they're not eight is yet well we'll give
ourselves some freedom but intuitively
like the parameter should all be looped
all be somewhere together
okay so what is that going to be 5 1
minus 5 plus
log
1 by 5. now we seem to be in kind of the
right situation because we have this
character here which kind of looks like
the interaction terms right Y and the
and model parameters are interacting and
we have something here that's isolated
that's just a function of the model
parameters okay now it's going to turn
out that Phi is not going to be equal to
Eta right because this thing here is not
of the right functional form
so we got to figure that out so what's
our what's our best guess for what this
ETA will be well why not what it looks
like 1 minus 5. okay
so we want to set to to show that it's
of the right form we want us we
postulate that this thing is actually
equal to Eta okay now that means this
thing here has to be some function of
ETA right
now that seems at one hand kind of
obvious right because it only depends on
Phi and that's a local transformation
for Phi but we're going to solve for it
explicitly if that kind of hand waving
implicit function theorem kind of
argument bothers you okay
right
so here our goal is we're going to take
Ty as again getting equal to y
we take ETA that way and we want to
understand what is the value of a and
what we claim it is right a of ETA or of
Nu is we claim that that's going to be
minus log of 1 by 5.
all right let's let's check that claim
right that shouldn't be hard and so why
does that work well
copy this guy
so this goes to well I just take e of
both sides
1 by 5
then I move this thing across right so
that I can I can do whatever I like 1
minus 5. equals Phi
then I want to make sure I get all the
files on one side
so I get 5 or 5 times e ETA plus one
and I'm off to the races right so now I
have 5 is equal to 1 plus e to the minus
ETA over one
okay
now
this means by the way
that log of 1 minus Phi
well that's going to be equal to oh
sorry did I
screw that up
let's make sure I didn't screw that up
I'm just going to redo this piece just
to make sure because I didn't do it in
my notes
um
so it's going to be oh no it's one I'm
right e to the FI okay so now I take 1
minus this
right so that's going to be equal log of
this is a lot of arithmetic to do in one
Peak setting
but this is going to be log of uh 1 plus
e to the ETA okay
so far so good so why does that satisfy
me because that's a function of ETA
right now as I said it's kind of
straightforward from here because these
things are just functions of each other
but this is technically what we needed
to do to show that these things are
actually equal and in fact
we're in good shape now
okay so what am I saying I'm saying like
this seems trivial on one hand because
you're like wow I could just put in
whatever I want but you can't put in
whatever you want you have to first
separate out the interaction between Y
and the firm and the form and then you
have to be able to pull out the term
that depends only on on new here the
parameters does that make sense
let's see another example please
[Music]
right I mean a is a function yeah
right that's just a function of a just
this happens to be a different one okay
now here's what's weird okay I don't
know if I should really mention this but
you should look this thing actually
remember I told you all the action was
in there
you can kind of look at this encoding
this is the log partition function so a
log is what we expected
this one plus e n thing well if you
think about like the different weights
on the spaces this is actually encoding
the fact that there's like a positive
and a negative State and try and think
about why that might actually be the
case in fact if we start to compute the
derivative of this thing it's actually
the expected value of y
that turns out not to be an accident
okay
all right okay before we get into that
let's go down one more okay so what did
I hope that you got it from this it's a
tedious thing to walk through you can
should walk through these on your own
there are three examples you should also
walk through the logistic kinds of
examples and the others
basically the whole thing is I want to
make it super clear what the statement
means I don't expect anything here to be
mind-blowing I don't think like our use
of fractions is gonna you know change
your lives I'm just saying that like
this is the content of the statement
clear right you give me a probability
distribution in one form I'm going to
translate it into a different problem
into a same functional form
such that it has you know satisfies
these conditions and then in that case
this Ada is now the this Ada is now
What's called the natural parameters
okay and you're typically not given the
function in the natural parameters right
and you're going to be responsible on
homework and in other places to do this
and the reason why is if you can do this
mapping then a bunch of stuff gets easy
inference gets easy learning gets easy
because now it turns out that you can
show and we'll talk about in a second
you can do gradient descent on these
parameters and it's going to be concave
and that's wild that you can solve all
these models the same way okay
so I just want to make sure that the
functional form is clear and the reason
we're doing it is because it's going to
simplify some stuff please
yeah awesome so could you use the T
function to massage in the form now in
this class if you find yourself doing
that too aggressively you've probably
done something wrong just as like a
heads up because we don't we don't use
it too much but yeah you could do that
in t if t or like expressed in some way
and you were only modeling a piece of it
uh as a result of this and saying the
probability distribution didn't depend
on one part like T was a projection you
could do that too but this is pretty
hard to get around so I think you're
thinking in exactly the right way kind
of like how do I get around and break
this and basically what it's saying is
your interactions are arbitrary and why
arbitrary
arbitrary and new and the interactions
between them occur in the X
right and that are linear and once they
have this linear interaction term
whatever the function T is those
sufficient statistics that's what you're
modeling up to and some folks asked and
I answer some Advanced questions on the
on Ed which none of you are responsible
to know about deriving things like uh
why is logistic regression calibrated in
certain ways in data
those features those sufficient
statistics are what feed into those
arguments so up to these sufficient
statistics this is how well you do so
when you play the game of massaging it
you're either throwing away information
uh or you're not in which case you know
that's what we're doing here yeah so
it's a modeling choice you could do it
nothing that presents you
but it means something about what you're
doing underneath the covers
okay this is awesome so so now you learn
something which again hopefully seems
sort of trivial you're like oh I can
take some I can take that distribution
of like heads and tails and put it into
this weird functional form and that
would be interesting because one thing
you should test your understanding of is
can you now given a bunch of samples
from heads and tails like estimate the
underlying parameters right Computing
derivatives here seems a little bit
nasty right these are like fives and y's
that are up in things it's like it looks
like a weird function once I put it in
this form all of a sudden like it's nice
and convex and life is good but I have
to look at estimating this parameter not
the original one is that making sense
please ask me a question if not
all right we'll see one more example and
we'll come back to it this is the only
important thing that from from what we
need to do now let's look at the
gaussian example two we'll only do these
two examples
okay this is the gaussian with fixed
variants
this one's really good
because remember what the probability of
Y is
going to look like sorry
one over
two pi
X and there is a negative
y minus mu Square over two Sigma Square
okay
let's make Sigma Square equal to one
actually make my life a little easier
okay just for no reason
okay now how do we get that in our
favorite form so let me go copy our
favorite form
seems to be pretty close right I mean
we're in pretty good shape
what do we need to do well we have to
factor it in some way so this constant
we can absorb anywhere we don't care
about that we have to somehow pull this
thing apart
okay so how are we going to do that
so we're going to put the 1 over 2 pi
square root 2 pi here
and then we're going to pull out the E
minus y squared over 2. okay so I'm just
going to factor this right this is going
to be minus y squared plus u squared
minus 2 mu y
over one half that's what this term is
going to be right let's just straight
multiplication so I factor out the e y
squared what does that leave me with
leaves me with X of
this character
mu y
minus
one half mu squared oops
minus one half mu squared
okay so what are our natural parameters
well
ETO is Mu which is why I accidentally
wrote it right at the beginning which
would have been a little bit weird to do
T of Y and a of n equals
one half
ETA Square oop mu squared okay
wow
no yeah
okay right so because this is Mu now
again notice I differentiate this thing
what's the expected value of this
of this character well it's mu right
but when I differentiate a y I get
exactly back mu which is kind of
interesting
this is Trivial here in the last example
it was non-trivial it was like a weird
function that I differentiated and I got
back the actual probability distribution
right which is kind of bizarre that I
would get that back
okay by the way if that's not clear
differentiate dysfunction with respect
to Ada and then see what you get
okay does that make sense
okay so just make sure we're verifying
everything Yep this looks right uh this
is my B term oh sorry this is my B term
I'll highlight in different colors
this is b y
this thing is the part log partition
function okay and what I'm just trying
to highlight is like this thing contains
like a lot of information about the
distribution in both of the examples
we've seen
please
no it's a wonderful question so right
now we're worried about the case where Y
is going to be a scalar which makes our
lives a little bit easier and so we're
going to look at that but you just have
to have that the t y and n and ETA
actually resolve to a scalar that
they're the same type so if you have if
your y has multiple dimensions then you
need more natural parameters that's
actually pretty important because
um that that's why they're and why we
call them natural like it's like your
problem has you know Dimension D then
you need deep free parameters
[Music]
foreign
there is not no you could the thing is I
wanted to have Sigma squared be
um fixed like I didn't want it to change
per data point that was important and so
it was easier to just write one there if
you put if you put Sigma squared in here
and it was just a constant then you
would just push it into the appropriate
spots and be done they would just fold
into this if Sigma squared were
something that we're changing per data
point right like we were trying to
estimate for every data point not only
it's mean but it's possible variance
like I give you a temperature reading
and I say like from all the data I've
seen I think it's 30 degrees but I know
that I haven't seen enough data so I'm
like plus or minus two degrees if I've
seen tons of data and I'm very confident
I'll say plus or minus 0.1 degrees right
that is an estimation where Sigma is
part of the model and then you would
have another free parameter for it great
question and try and write that out I
don't know if that example is written
out in the notes if you get stuck or
whatever please send me a note I'll
write it up for you on it
does that make sense that capture your
question
awesome
okay
yeah awesome so two questions on the on
the live thread
um the examples to go through on your
own are the ones in the hand and the
typed written notes which contain these
in one more but just go through them on
your own like I'll just wax pull
whatever one minute if you haven't
studied for a mathematically minded
course the way that I always do it did
it I still actually read textbooks and
course notes and everything else is I
read them I watch the lecture or
whatever it is then I try and remember
those key spots and I try to derive them
myself it's the fastest way to figure
out what didn't stick so if you're like
oh I can write the derivative in two
minutes and you walk away well okay you
know everything for the lecture if you
get stuck it's a really good signal that
you don't do it if you don't do it and
then that builds over time something
that you thought was trivial and you
didn't actually put the time into will
end up biting you right just lesson that
I learned from too many years at the
University why is the derivative equal
to the expected value I'm not going to
prove that I will just assert it here I
just want to show that oops sorry I just
want you to observe that in both cases
it's true it's a wonderful question
okay
it just takes a little bit of arithmetic
to show it's a wonderful question yeah
yeah okay so I'm just gonna I'm gonna
put those assertions in here now so why
do we care about this form
first is what we said inference is easy
okay
the expected value of y
given ETA is the partial derivative with
respect to the Natural parameters of a
of n okay I would encourage you to
compute this on all the examples
okay you don't want it proving the
general thing just takes a little bit of
extra thing but on all the examples so
far you've seen it's clearly true
and then why that's true in general is
because it's the log of the sum of all
the possible outcomes proving it for
continuous stuff takes a little bit more
effort
okay so don't don't worry about it okay
but we've seen this as true okay and
this this pattern holds
the variance
is also the second derivative
of n
okay now this pattern you may think
holds like oh the third power is good no
it doesn't work that way okay just these
first two
that's the only ones that matter okay
these are the only ones that work okay
so why is this so interesting to me one
because once you take your distribution
whatever the crazy distribution is
however wild it is and distributions can
get pretty insane there's you know
uncountably many of them you put them
into this form you basically have a
mechanical procedure to do inference and
to do uh you know variance estimation
inference more important to us but that
also means that you can do learning
right and in fact learning is well
defined
okay in particular
this function is going to be concave in
data
okay well let me write it this way
the mle remember we did the maximum
likelihood estimator for all those
things previously
is concave
okay
please
that helps yeah so that is definitely a
piece of it you have to do one extra
step but you're exactly on the right
thing that's exactly how you can go and
prove it just compute it directly right
and see that it's positive the second
derivative is positive everywhere then
it's
um then it's comebacks but yeah
so you have to there's a negative in
front but that's a monster
wonderful yeah
exactly right that's that's if you
remember last time the way we framed all
of our estimation problems was take the
log likelihood that was there L of theta
and then use gradient descent on that
and this is basically saying that the
resulting formulation if I use the
natural parameters is always guaranteed
to be concave
please
yeah so the thing is you can compute
this directly by looking at exactly when
you compute the derivative and and pull
it out the way that you do it I'm not
going to prove it in class but I'll just
tell you like it's not a mysterious
statement what you do is you look at all
of the for the discrete case you look at
the fact that it's a log partition means
it's the sum over all the possible
worlds meaning all the possible ways
that y could be assigned right so
there's going to be a term in there for
each one of them because it sums over
all of them that's what it does so maybe
this is getting way too abstract and
mysterious maybe this is better to prove
so if I look here look at this this part
of the distribution this may not sum to
one right if I just started to do it so
like if I took and summed over y oops
if I sum y of this expression let's call
this g y
it may not equal 1. it's not guaranteed
to be equal to one okay because it's
just some collection of values and some
other stuff this thing
uh is the the function this ETA here
makes sure that it's equal to one so
it's the scalar as we were talking about
before that make sure whatever this sums
to it's going to divide over it so it's
sometimes written as 1 over Z the part
the part partition function however that
means that the way you get it one
derivation of it is you sum over all the
different values so it is like the sum
of everything over one is actually what
so this character has to be equal to
this
right because it has to cancel out it
has to be actually equal to 1 when I
compute it and that means that it's
basically of the form a sum over all the
possible values of Y
and so if you compute the derivative
inside when you take the log of that
each one of the Y's is going to come
down next to exactly this functional
form
all right so if if that's too mysterious
I didn't want to prove it because it
gets like
strange but I'm happy to write out the
proof it's super super straightforward
okay awesome so all I care about this
the thing that I'm trying to get across
because I'm trying to give you a guided
tour I don't want to get to I want to do
enough details that you see all the
pieces so you can go back and understand
how they work but I don't want to get
bogged down in things that I don't think
are like super critical for you to
understand
um and also I don't want to do things
that I think you should do on your own
because doing them mechanically will
teach you better than me like
inscrutably writing for the hundredth
time how to prove this
um but if I'm wrong and you want to
watch me incredibly right I can I don't
know you can log into a twitch stream or
something
um awesome all right all good
okay so clear enough like why we did
this
so barring these assertions if you get
your probability distribution into this
form then all of a sudden you get
inference and learning and a bunch of
other stuff for free
however one of the things is as was
correctly pointed out there was a little
bit of a bait and switch here we started
last time to think about various
different models and how we put those
models inside so where did the data in X
go and that's what we actually need to
figure out here okay all right so let's
talk about generalized linear models
foreign
that I really want you to get across is
these are all design assumptions okay so
these are all design choices that you
can actually make in your model and
we'll get to them and and talk about
what you want to do okay and you can
also think about them as assumptions
all right so
first what we're going to say is we're
going to claim that the distribution of
our label given X for some parameters
Theta follows an exponential family okay
now I claim without much justification
here that this is an important family
now you can say it's an important family
because as we'll talk about many
different data types like fall into this
that you've seen so if you look at
binary things
you want to do y as binary well that's
Bernoulli right so we looked at that
classification
if you want to have real valued wise
well we have a couple of them that we
could use but we saw gaussians okay
if you want to do counts like you're
actually counting like uh you know how
many people walk by a particular uh
thing or how many packets arrive at a
server or something like that then
that's a different distribution it's
called poisson okay
if it's oh you want all the whole real
line right you don't want you want real
positive line well there's two different
fancy distributions there called gamma
right you don't need to know these per
se but what I'm trying to explain to you
kind of proof by writing a lot and
gesturing wildly is that these oh sorry
exponential
laplacian's also in this
uh if you want distributions just one
more then this is called the duration
distribution
so what am I trying to get across here
these are probably most of the
distributions you've heard of there are
more that I'm not writing down but they
all fall into this exponential family
now one hypothesis is that we figured
out this technology and that's why we
described distributions this way but
that's actually not true we went the
other way around we were doing things ad
hoc for each one of them and this tied
them up and put them nicely together
okay so you pick your error mode and the
way you pick the error mode is it has to
have the right type if you're observing
binary data you want to use a Bernoulli
right or something that has a binary
type if you're observing real data you
want to use a gaussian counts plus on so
on okay so there's a data type mapping
here right the second thing that you
have
is that your natural parameters and this
is where they come back in are going to
be of this following form
with Theta
element of r d plus one
and X also element of r d plus one
okay
so here
we're going to make the assumption that
after subject to noise our model varies
linearly
with some underlying features okay now
you're going to see later there's
actually a more powerful assumption than
you realize if you take your model to be
very very large and have a huge number
of features almost everything becomes
linear in that space High dimensional
geometry is very very weird so it's not
like if you think in low Dimensions
you're like oh there's only so many
lines I can draw I can't separate out my
data if you take your data and you know
put it up into a huge dimensional space
odds are it will be linearly separable
there'll be a line through it we'll come
back to that okay so this is just the
thing there
and then three once you've made that
assumption
your inference is super easy
right a test time
you output
e of Y
given X and Theta
okay I said another way
h of state of x equals
T of Y given X
okay
so hopefully this makes sense okay so
I'll walk through exactly what's going
to happen in one second just to make
sure it's it's clear but this means that
we're doing this prediction and one
thing that we sneaked past you was that
when we went to logistic regression all
of a sudden we started with these
hypothesis where instead of returning
like yes or no we just returned a
probability distribution over it okay
and that was a that was a change right
when we're doing regression we returned
to just a value here we're just
returning actually like your probability
that you think y has a particular value
that's what you do for inference that's
how inference is defined okay so let me
make sure this is super clear how this
works your data comes in as X
it then goes into your linear model
you compute Phi transpose x with your
parameters this is your box
you get out Ada right Theta T becomes
ETA and the parameter you have before
you feed that to your exponential model
X model does whatever it does there's
B's and T's and whatever in there but
now you know your value for Ada
or new whatever you want I'm using both
and then if you want to train you do Max
over five of log p y x
Phi
if you want to do inference
you do ey
X5 okay this is learning
this is inference
okay so all you pick here is you pick
your your data you pick the features and
then you run this procedure and
everything's kind of you know automated
for you in the sense that like
um yeah in the sense that you now know a
general recipe to do maximum likelihood
estimation and do inference it's not
obvious how to do that by the way there
are scenarios where we don't know how to
do maximum likelihood estimation so
right now like your universe is like oh
everything you've shown me you've done
maximum likelihood estimation it's been
really easy I'm like yeah that's fair
but there's a big world out there of
stuff that is hard to cram into this and
so what this says is if you can put it
into this form maximum likelihood
estimation and inference becomes super
super easy
okay and learning here has a nice form
data J looks like this
and you can directly check this
plus alpha y i
minus
H Theta of x i
x j i
so why is that the case well we saw that
it was the case in all the other models
you just have to go through and compute
the derivative and convince yourself but
now that it's in this form just
Computing the derivatives with respect
to Theta as you go through here because
it occurs only in this Theta TX we'll
get that out so one of the reasons I was
delaying proving it in the special cases
is because you have to do all of these
transformations to put it into the right
the right nice form and then when I
compute the derivative my life gets
really really easy if you compute it in
the natural parameters it looks weird
but if I mean if you computed in the
original parameters it looks weird but
if you compute it this way life is
pretty good okay
and this by the way
here is always this thing
right always hypothesis
okay
so far so good
please
yeah so let's actually it's a great
question let me do one more example and
then hopefully that will become clear
about how they relate
um
I wanna yeah so let me just run through
logistic regression then I think that'll
probably maybe answer that question
um
so it'll show exactly how they fit
together
terminology okay so there's the model
parameter
this is Phi
there's the natural parameter which in a
linear model
we always substitute a generalized
linear model we always substitute this
was the Ada before and then there's the
canonical parameters
parameters okay so these were like five
for Bernoulli okay
uh or mu and sigma Square for gaussians
okay and this G here we're going to call
the canonical response G inverse
so G is called a canonical response
okay so why do I do this I want to make
sure it's really clear what all the
pieces are and what's going on here
there's some model parameters that's the
thing that we're going to solve with
respect to that's the thing that we're
going to do gradient descent on that's
the thing that we're going to do the H
data over with respect to Theta is then
dotted into the model or the data that's
what this x is this is data right here
that becomes the natural parameter which
then goes to the which the exponential
model now tells you how to operate on
okay and then I can do everything I want
on the natural parameter that's what
tells me the distribution and so in the
case we're doing logistic regression
which we'll talk about in one second you
have a linear thing and then your errors
are of the form I make an error you know
that I sometimes switch to class if you
like I get the wrong answer with some
some uh probability and then there's
this link which are these canonical
parameters and this is the content of
what we're talking about here is you
write them down in these canonical
parameters and then they have people
write them down in whatever messy form
we found them and I'm asserting that a
lot of them can be put into that nice
exponential form through what's called
this canonical response function or its
link function and that allows us to
treat them in the same way so this is
super important because when you
encounter one of these distributions you
probably encounter it in this form you
have to put it into this form and then
that lets you do everything that we just
talked about in one clean way learning
becomes this nice simple rule inference
becomes this nice simple rule
okay
awesome
all right
okay so let's look at logistic
regression just so it's super clear what
that means
all right so H Theta of x
well we said it's the expected value of
y given X
and some parameters Theta okay
this Theta right so we have
right so there's uh theta equals one
plus one Theta minus n
and then the model one over one plus
Theta oops
e to the minus Theta TX okay
so this piece here
Theta was our was our or sorry Theta
should be driven sorry this was our
model parameter this was after we
transformed to the Natural parameters
that's this character and this is what
we wrote down last time
so when we went to do logistic
regression remember we had a loss
function that looked like this this was
our sigmoid or logistic function and
then what I'm saying is is that we right
now to get the derivatives and do
everything else which I skated on last
time I now no longer have to skate on
because I just made it more abstract I
transform it into this parameter space
and I'm good
okay so in one hand as I said it's
totally trivial I'm just doing a
transformation of how I represent the
numbers but it also seems weird that I
can do this and I'm inserting that in
these cases I can
and that's what allows us to go and
treat all those different distributions
in some way so if I give you some
features
you dot forward you learn a model and
then you have an error like I'm looking
at counts I'm observing them counts have
a very different distribution than the
errors I would expect on zero one things
or the errors I would expect on a linear
regression I just plug that model in
that natural Model N and outfall is a
pretty reasonable class of machine
learning models okay
and you may say the thing that people
usually react to is they say something
like well what if I want to do something
that's more complicated than linear but
linear is pretty powerful I can take my
features and square them I can multiply
them together it's still linear right I
can take my feature five could be the
you know product of the preceding seven
and so this turns out to be a wildly
popular class of machine learning models
in fact our entire books that are
written about generalized linear models
there's a citation to McCullough which
is the standard reference I'm not sure I
advise necessarily reading it but it's
uh the standard reference not because
it's not a great book just like you know
it's long
okay please
do you think that there will be more
improvements in the theory of machine
learning such that quadratic and other
models are more applicable in these
folks right now when you're extremely
powerful we're going to make a lot of
sense yeah
I am I I really feel like I should buy
you something so that's a great question
so there's a lot of folks that have done
through the years but as we'll talk
about when you get to kernels things
like polynomial kernels and exponential
kernels and those are very powerful ways
to model the world what I was kind of
hinting at before is the linear model
has this sneaky out in the back which is
you get to pick the features so if you
know up front that like you want it that
the squares of the temperatures are more
indicative than the you know the raw
values you can just put that into your
model and and learn more and more
features and so it's not a question of
like you know eventually we're going to
get powerful and use those features we
can use them today the crazy thing is we
can reduce a lot of the things you would
naturally do to this model and you'll
see eventually you know someone was
asking about these infinite dimensional
feature models those are what kernels
are you can reduce those to linear in an
infinite dimension space so it's wildly
like uh you know important there to do
this the other bit which is also you
know my personal opinion on these things
one of the things that has really bitten
me again and again is that simple stupid
things work extraordinarily well with a
given enough data and in fact the trend
has been larger and larger amounts of
data for the last 40 years and every
time we think it's going to run out of
gas and get fancy a bunch of fancy
people academics start writing papers
about clever ways to do X Y or Z and
usually they get smoked by more data and
linear stuff and there's a great paper
about this that I can post of like
different eras of machine learning when
this happened and like the thing that's
remarkable about modern machine learning
to me is not how sophisticated it is but
how we basically do the same thing and
just pour in mountains of data like
right now there's a particular model
that's very hot in five years will it be
hot I don't know right maybe five years
ago it wasn't I guess five years ago was
kind of hot but you know and then a new
one will come but the pattern of like we
just dump in all this information and
just optimize the crap out of these
parameters like that works really well
so the Sim so the thing I'm trying to
get across there is as you said is like
the future of machine learning seems to
me to be more tied with like under
understanding relatively simple
applications when we have huge amounts
of data underneath the covers
um yeah but I'm a zealot there I taught
the large language model course with
Tatsu last quarter so I'm a Believer you
can think it's nonsense it's a personal
opinion but wonderful question
yeah awesome others
all right so again you know same thing
I'll do gaussian just just to stall to
make sure this is clear because I hope
you know if I'm very optimistic I'm here
like oh this is obvious uh there's
there's no content here I understand it
perfectly if we are in that Universe
like I will be extremely happy if you're
like baffled please ask me a question
um
this is the same this is a gaussian how
do I do prediction well when I have
something I pick the mean value that I
would have that's exactly the same piece
that's here how do I do the estimation
well that's exactly Theta TX that's what
we were doing before when we fit a line
okay
same thing
so all that's all I'm saying is what
we've done so far in the first K
lectures we've now compressed to
basically one equation
one schema of this thing
we now know how to do inference and we
know how to do learning and maybe it's
tough to appreciate in the sense that
you're like well I didn't encounter a
thousand models before but now all these
different models can be shoehorned into
this and that's quite powerful and we'll
use that quite a bit later when we do
you know much more uh kind of advanced
stuff
right awesome
if there are no questions I'm going to
move on to multi-class
all right so the last thing I want to
describe here which is important for you
and I think you have to use in your
homework
is uh how we deal with multi-class
classification and I should say
the trend has been in machine learning
not only these big models that I was
just excited and ranting about which you
can you know take or leave
but
is that you train models
on a variety of tasks more broad than
even a variety of classes you train them
to do many things at once in fact
weirdly as I may have told you the the
thing that we seem to be doing as a
field right now is training a model to
do something task a and then using it
for task B and weirdly that makes the
model more robust so the typical task
that we do there by the way is
predicting the next word which is a
really seems like a really basic task
you look at a sentence and you produce
of all you view the words as
individually it's just oversimplified
but how it works every token is a class
right so is the word cat dog whatever
you just take a vocabulary of 50 000
words let's say and then you predict
which one do you think is likely to be
in the next space so I read the first
part of the sentence and I predict this
turns the entire web into a training
Corpus right because now any piece of
text I can evaluate in a multi-class way
we train it just to do that and weird
Behavior emerges like it can write
pieces of code for you it can answer
questions in narrative form
and only when we train it on lots and
lots and lots of data and it's a little
bit spooky so anyway so this is what
multi-class is for and this is this is
actually you know something that we use
every day
[Music]
um
awesome wonderful question what is the
disconnect between the power of linear
models and the need for non-linear
components in a neural net wonderful
question so right now what we've done is
we've said and the exchange was
wonderful hey what about more powerful
feature representations what neural Nets
basically are and why they're so amazing
is and they take your data if you like
and they pick out what those features
are what those X's should be from the
underlying data and then usually on the
end you just have a linear model that's
you know there's little tweaks and
variations but that's pretty much what
you have so the question of where does
The X come from you give me an image of
a cat how do I get good features about
images
that's what the neural net is actually
solving and that's where we need
non-linearity but it comes in at that
piece not at the prediction piece
great questions
all right so here we're going to look at
discrete values if you're familiar with
distributions up to some fixed k
so we have uh cat you know dog
car
I don't know whatever else oh I wanted
one other one oh bus
okay
so here K is 4.
all right so I want to predict among
that set it's kind of weird I promise
you that you're only going to see a cat
a dog a car a bus you could ask well
what if I show it a horse
it's not it doesn't have to predict You
can predict whatever it wants in that
situation right but
um for this case imagine that I'm just
distinguishing among those four classes
or the crazy example I gave you where
your classes are every word and say the
English language
okay
all right how do you encode this
it's encoded as a one-hotvector
it's called a one-hot vector
right and the distribution the error
distribution is the thing that we just
talked about
to the k
okay
so uh such that you know sum y equals
one
okay equals one
okay so there's a vector that's in zero
one but it's precisely one thing is is
uh lit up so for example you could have
you know the cat one is one zero zero
zero this could be cat
zero one zero zero this could represent
dog
you get the pattern zero zero one zero
this could represent car
and so on okay
so those vectors basically these one hot
vectors they seem pretty wasteful but
you don't have to store all the zeros
it's not as bad as it looks
um but like this is how you intuitively
think mathematically think about how the
data looks okay clear enough so we've
reduced our problem from uh you know
dealing with these categorical labels to
dealing with vectors
now let's try to classify them
all right so let's draw a quick picture
okay
oops
so let's imagine our data looks like
this so there are some class ones which
I guess are cats here there are some
buses here which are fours there are
some dogs here
I'm just drawing all nice and clustered
of course your native never really looks
like this but that's okay
all right
so what do I what do I want in this
situation okay I want lines so this is
you know this is corresponding to one
class
you know as I said this is the cat class
this is the dog class
so on
so how does multi-dimensional how does
this uh how does this multi-class thing
work that's too close
the colors don't really matter but I've
started so now I'm going to finish
all right
car bus okay so what do I want here what
I need to do is I want to pick because
we're looking at linear separators for
this I kind of want to look at
you know what I'll do is
I'll pick a line
that for example separates the cats
from everything else okay so this will
be something this will be you know Theta
1.
X is equal to zero so this is the line
I'm drawing here so I want to pick Theta
right so that on one side are the cats
and then the other side is everything
else
does that intuitively make sense right
for Theta 2 for Theta 4 what would I
like to do well I'd also like to pick
something where you know here
oops
Theta 4 dot x equals zero so I like it
so that again the buses are on one side
and everything else is there now if you
look at this geometrically it becomes
pretty clear by the way like there's
lots of choices right I could have
picked here I could have picked there
right what we will try and prefer
sometimes called Max margin we actually
prefer that it's kind of as far away
from the two data points as possible
it's like as close to in the middle as
possible you can verify that actually
makes sense and
um you can verify that that's actually
what we'll you'll hope will happen I get
something like this
all right
this is X3 so in this case by the way
which is really nice
everything is nice and linear separable
right this side has the dogs on it
this side has the cars on it and so on
okay
so there's one line that explains
uh you know that kind of can separate
each one of them
now the question is
how do you pick
right
so the way you do it right
is
when you get a point
you're going to compute
its value against each one of them Theta
1 Theta 2 Theta three I'm just going to
draw the first ones
first three yeah data four whatever okay
and these are going to give me some
values okay and the values are going to
be basically you can think about as like
you know kind of how close are they to
the various lines
it's a DOT product
I'm just saying like this is the line
where on this side Theta is going to be
yeah so for this side Theta is going to
be positive and on this side it's going
to be negative all over here right and
so I'm just drawing like the deciding
line so as you're more cat-like you're
getting a higher score from this you're
getting something that's like you know a
larger score Azure here you're getting a
negative cat score okay
right so the point is each one of these
things because of that is going to give
you great question is going to give you
some score so maybe it's a cat so it
looks like you know this thing
0.1 and everybody else is like yeah I'm
not really sure maybe I'm I'm kind of
like borderline about all the other
classes this is what you would hope
would happen okay each model gives me a
score
and then okay
so what happens
yeah yeah great question so right now
remember like you give me a horse and
you put the horse in a center who knows
right who knows what I'll get I will be
able to run this procedure and it will
be confused so one of the things that
happens in neural Nets by the way is
that they're in large scale models is
when you're really high dimensional
right and you have a bunch of uh a bunch
of these lines and other things there
will be Pockets that are actually
nowhere close to anything but now look
it's totally well defined this character
here has a normal this way this one will
get a negative it will get a negative
score from everybody
right now you can look and say if it
gets a negative score from every single
thing maybe I should be suspicious of it
but that's not in general something that
will happen it one of these
unfortunately will be higher than the
others like if it's here it may be
closer to cat and so it says oh it's a a
cat that was near the border or
something like that and it will pick but
let's get to the procedure first before
talking about the exceptions
okay so we have all of these then what
happens we exponentiate them right 0.7
minus 0.5
0.1 so on
and then this actually leads to
probabilities right actually let's make
this really negative because like minus
10. either minus 10. then these things
are approximately like you know uh 2.1
whatever so on I get the values out and
then I normalize them
by summing all of them so I sum all
these together so I sum all these
characters sum Theta I dot X and that
gives me some value Z and I divide this
number by Z divide this number by Z and
that's going to give me a number between
0 and 1. because I sum them up and
they're all positive so 0.5 0.17
so on
2.5 up okay the point is is I compute
this exponential I sum oops it should be
e of this thing
and then that is my normalizing term
I sum it up so let me write it in a
cleaner form
it's a falling thing
so the probability of Y
equals to X
a probability of y equal to
k
is given X and Theta has the falling
form it's X of
Theta K dot X over some K sum J all
right X Theta J dot X
okay J goes from 1 to K
okay I just described the procedure in
elaborate detail here but this is
basically what's going on okay this is
exactly what's going on it's not
basically
please
[Music]
okay so two things one is this makes
sure that everything is so exactly as we
were talking about before these are each
think about these as each like a
logistic regression model so in the
logistic regression model you take this
and get the natural parameter then you
exponentiate it
if you had an offset like if you had
some function there you would still need
just as we did in the exponential model
you need to sum to make it a probability
distribution so that's where the Z comes
up so the x is because we're doing these
General linear models and that gives us
the nice kind of functional form that we
wanted underneath the covers that we've
been using in all our predictive
problems for in the class or not think
about logistic regression binary or not
and then we have many different scores
and then the procedure is just to
normalize them
okay and this kind of makes sense right
it's like this is saying like how strong
a classification I am right if these
cats like if there's a cat way over here
maybe this is a super cat like the
clearest picture of a cat you've ever
seen in that case like it should get a
really high score and you should be
really confident in it that's the
intuition now is that always true no
certainly not a picture of a horse could
show up over here
we hope it doesn't
but mechanically is this clear what
happens
right
yeah so exactly so this is basically a
compact form of what we'd call One
Versus All which is like okay how
confident is my cat detector how
confident is my dog detector how
confident is my whatever this is car
detector I don't know what that is
does that make sense
and so you just bake off their relative
strengths that's how you do multi-class
classification at once
all right so how do you train this
well what you're given
is you're given something that looks
like this
say one two three put four in there
you're told it's a cat you have
probability one here and you have zero
everywhere else this is what you're
actually given that's what the label
looks like okay your probability your P
hat your estimate will not look like
that
it will actually look like oh I'm pretty
confident it's a cat but I have little
pieces at each one of the others one two
three four okay maybe some spike okay
this is at inference time
what I'm trying to get across is when
you actually look at these things they
will give you Pro small probabilities
that it's everywhere because it's doing
this normalization
okay now one thing that people do by the
way is something they call label
smoothing
they take this and they push a small
amount of mass everywhere else
right so you take the one and you kind
of say like I'm going to put a small
tiny amount of mass everywhere else and
that's basically to account for the fact
that your labels are often wrong right
you're you contain you know even very
popular well-studied benchmarks will
have you know three percent of their
labels be wrong or something so you can
imagine how you would kind of smooth and
and why that would be bad when you're
training a system if you're like it's
definitely not a cat you're like no no
there's a small possibility it's a cat I
should admit that possibility that's a
very different statement if you imagine
those two
okay awesome so what happens here well
the great thing is is like this follows
exactly
what we've been doing the whole time so
we we now introduce the this is also
sometimes a cross entropy term
right which is equal to this guy but
this follows basically our basic recipe
which is I said Pui
uh equals K Times log
P hat
uh of Y
this equals minus log
pyi
okay so this is the ground truth label
okay so this is in case we don't do
smoothing basically our loss to minimize
the cross entropy is the same as
minimizing the log of our expected
probability and that thing has a very
fancy name that's a logit
and that's the you'll see these negative
log likelihood things all over machine
learning packages that's what they're
doing okay
and this equals
just so we're super clear it equals
minus log of x
Theta I dot X over sum X Theta J dot x j
goes from 1 to K okay and this is what
we minimize
that's it
and so how do you solve this model
just run gradient descent
all right
that's it
right
any questions about this
um what part of that is to launch it
again oh the logit is a log probability
great question so this is the this is
the terminology for a log probability
so this thing comes up the reason I call
that is you'll probably encounter that
term I just wanted you to be familiar
with it and you don't usually predict
you don't actually write out the
probability functions you don't take the
X you actually just take the log of
those probabilities and that's what you
actually minimize and so you you will
use them and they're in log scale so
you'll often see like machine learning
codes spit out these like you know
negative seven negative four or three
point two one that's what they that's
what they are they're logits you'll see
that term logic everywhere
yes please
uh because the otherwise it would be a
maximization
yeah it's just to make the function sign
so that we have a minimization wonderful
question yeah please remember your
minimizing yeah what it doesn't look
like it has any dependence
oh awesome question what a wonderful
question yeah it's hidden right here
this Theta I
this I is the ground truth I right
that's what this is this statement is
this is the ground
no it's just like you picked out that
one and then you get a your your loss
function kind of like perfectly encodes
it if you put in the label smoothing
then in fact it's not just one Theta I
that's there they each get a weighting
associated with them as well but here
that was the trick this Yi is the same
as the actual ground wonderful wonderful
question
yeah great question yeah yeah so so here
it's the Theta X and then I'm I'm taking
exponential but you would also have like
an X point over X spin yeah but here for
this model I don't do that so if so what
you're saying is an alternate model
where you take all the logistic
regressions and you just say like what's
the probability of each one and then you
compare them and I'm saying no you do it
in terms of the logits here and this is
how you bake them off all at the same
time the difference between them is not
super critical but this is the one we
use but it's a great point that they're
different so I did kind of by sleight of
hand here I said oh this is like you're
doing a logistic regression but this
again is like saying so if you think
about logistic regression as there's a
yes class and a no class in the yes
class I have the weight is X above Theta
T the X this is each thing that this is
the weight of every one of those
possible worlds and then I'm summing
over all of them and so that's why this
is consistent with logistic regression
imagine a null world that occurred here
that said it's either the class one or
it's none of the classes and so it's
feature I'm just going to default to one
because I don't care it could be any
scalar the knife gets you exactly back
to logistic regression does that make
the connection clear yeah so they really
are the same I just derived them in a
slightly different way
wonderful question please
um
yeah so uh if you've seen so this is a
new function I guess for us potentially
we have seen it because of the
discussion we just had and another guys
it actually is the binary cross entropy
is the logistic function
and so this is a generalization of that
and if you've ever seen entropy or cross
entropy which I think you know it
doesn't matter if you've seen or not
this is it right it's just a functional
form that we care about it's a kind of a
distance between probability
distributions
I care whatever reason I say this is not
because I think there's something
mystical here so if you haven't seen
entry before I guess this would be
mysterious and potentially even if you
have seen entropy before because entropy
is a mysterious thing
um but this is the loss function that
you use and it it's the reason you use
it is because it generalizes in the way
we just talked about
I don't think you need to know any of
that
so please
X and Y right
there's no Y in this diagram but yeah
uh so this here x is a two-dimensional
Vector this is a little bit of a weird
plot right X is cat as a two-dimensional
Vector because I only have two
Dimensions to draw on and so I put them
there and that's why this picture looks
a little bit different than maybe you're
thinking about it as like a function or
a curve or something but that's that's
the difference
higher Dimensions but it's exactly right
so in higher Dimensions what you would
expect is rather than lines which are
one-dimensional you'd expect you know D
minus one dimensional big planes that
were separating everything out
hyperplanes and then they would be live
on one side or the other and you would
care about the distance effectively
there and so I'm drawing like the
Contour representation of the function
right yeah awesome question
and then there's no the Y's are encoded
as we were just discussing by which
index I use right
foreign
oh awesome question yeah so we'll talk
about PCA when I come back to join you
and why we use that PCA is a method so
the two things PCA fix for you is if you
have X's that have different scales or
have different meanings like you know if
all your temperatures are between 80 and
82 degrees but they're really
significant PCA is a way of centering
and whitening your data meaning like
subtracting off the mean and
standardizing and normalizing that and
so that's a technique that is very very
commonly used in statistical analysis
and so we'll talk about that and how to
provably find that and what does
justifications for here when you're
doing things like image analysis
actually the the methods have been more
toward raw features and raw pixels over
the last couple of years where you the
things that we're all excited about is
to try and have no hand coding in the
pipeline you can talk philosophically
about why we're obsessed with this but
basically the newest models just take
the image raw and they try to have as
minimal what we call they call it
inductive bias but I won't Define that
term but as minimal kind of information
about the model to learn from them so
one weird fact that got me very excited
a year or two ago was that we have one
model for text and we were using that
same model and getting nearly
state-of-the-art accuracy on text and
images and audio in a bunch of different
places and that is the thing that's
really interesting and it starts from
the raw pixels and it learns The Edge
detectors and all the stuff we used to
do by hand so that's been the trend here
we'll talk a little bit about more about
featureprep because that stuff doesn't
always work and when it breaks you want
to kind of have a library to fall back
on wonderful question but that'll be in
like I guess week five four five
oh my God what a great question yeah
what if you can't draw this pretty
picture it doesn't make sense yeah
that's possible so what if your features
are bad right what if it turns out that
like your features about cats were like
they sleep on couches you're like well
dog sometimes sleeps on couches then you
couldn't possibly separate the dogs and
the cats it's a stupid example but like
your features could be could be so weak
that they're not able to actually
separate your class uh
imagine putting a lot more features in
and that's why these models that have
bigger and bigger Dimensions come in to
separate automatically all the different
classes but now your real question is
like okay well okay there's a fix but I
have my features and I train what
happens you just make misclassifications
and that's actually the default you have
a small number of features and then you
fit those features and you know you do
the best you can so like if a cat jumped
over here
there's a cat that was here you just
misclassified and you'd get it wrong
right you go from here over to here and
then you'd be toast so that does happen
quite a bit sometimes due to label error
and sometimes like there's a subfield of
machine learning
um that is kind of obsessed with this
and my students write papers in it
there's a great Benchmark called Wilds
from Percy and Chelsea and a couple
other folks on the faculty that have
these places where machine learning
picks out the wrong feature
systematically like you take a bird that
normally is on water and you photograph
it with a land background and the
Machine learning model is like oh that's
a land burn not a water bird there's a
lot of that going on so that that
absolute 100 happens
wonderful question
any other questions
all right so just to recap
what do we do today we went through this
exponential family of models and now
we've hopefully tied in a bow the fact
that we like had this method to our
Madness about doing binary and then real
value uh we you know we went real valued
in binary because we had seen fitting
lines we did classification and we tied
them all up in these exponential family
models we talked about why inference and
learning were you know basically the the
same in these models that let us
generalize to a whole host of them this
is the Workhorse of supervised machine
learning but the questions that you're
asking now are exactly the right
questions where do these features come
from what if the features don't fit the
data how do I get more expressive things
you're going to see things about kernels
and sem and neural Nets in the next
couple of lectures and that will tell
you how do you pick your features and
how do you get to these more expressive
models and that will form the bulk of
supervised machine learning then the
next section will come to unsupervised
and we'll forget the whys and figure out
what structure can we get there and
that's when we'll get into questions
like PCA we'll get into these questions
about what are called exponential family
models or em models where you have a
supervised predictor and an unsupervised
thing and this allows you to do some
pretty wild stuff like you know fit data
from the from quasars and stuff and
we'll we'll walk through all that stuff
and the fact that we'll also have a
thing on self-supervision which is a new
lecture uh just this time I guess my
student gave it last year but thank you
thanks so much for your time attention
have a wonderful rest of your week